okay we're live good afternoon cs19 how
are you guys doing
today oh fantastic that is what I like
to hear we have another Wonderful class
for you we're going to be learning about
independence oh my God I feel like in
the beginning of Cs 109 we just hit like
great core topic after great core topic
every thing we've been talking about
these first few weeks they're so Central
to just probalistic understanding of our
world that we'll show you about the
world works but also fundamental to
building algorithms that can make
decisions under uncertainty what a good
time to be studying
probability as I mentioned we've talked
about a whole bunch of important stuff
so as you guys see it I just wanted to
review a little bit some of the
important stuff we've talked about last
class we introduced this idea of
conditional probability H and I know at
this point in CS 109 A lot of people
will find it confusing to think about
the difference of conditional
probability and the probability of
end so in this world A and B are two
different events and you can ask two
different questions about them you can
ask what's the probability that both
those events happened that's what we
mean by and and this is a totally
different question this is what's the
chance that a happens given that B has
already occurred now to be clear if a
happens it is the case that both have
happened but the reason this question is
different is we're not guessing if B has
happened we're being told B has in fact
happened you entering the world where B
takes place conditional probabilities
are very exciting but they are a little
bit hard the very first time you learn
about
them now that really does introduce
three major questions we've thought
about in CS 109 we have probability of
the end of two events probability the or
of two events um or this conditional
probability I don't want anyone to get
lost in notation we borrow a lot from
set notation and as such set notation
has many ways of writing the exact same
thing
if at any point you're like what does a
comma mean just raise your hand please
other people will be confused a comma
means actually and it is set notation
shortcut for an for and sometimes people
don't even put the common they just put
two events next to each other and
somehow you're supposed to mean no that
this means and crazy set people U and
similarly for or there's a few different
pieces of
notation when we learned about
conditional probability we learned the
definition of conditional probability
which says here's how you calculate the
probability of an event happening given
another event has already occurred is
the probability both of them Happening
divid by the probability of the thing
you're conditioning on if you took that
equation and rearranged it you would get
the chain rule which says hey are you
interested in calculating the
probability that two events happen well
that's equal to the probability that one
event happens multiplied by the
probability that the other event
happened given that you just told me
what event F has already
occurred that would been so much to have
done in two weeks but we took it a
little bit further we also learned the
law of total probability and the law of
total probability says well if I want to
calculate the probability of event
happening I can think about the case
where some background event F occurs and
I can think about a different case where
the background event F doesn't occur and
that gives me a formula for going from
conditional probabilities to just
probabilities without conditions and
then finally we learn about base theorem
and if there's a single major key
something you 10 out of 10 100% have to
know in CS 109 is B theorem is such a
powerful useful tool a little bit
unintuitive but that's why it shows up
in so many interesting algorithms and
base theorem allows you to go between
calculating conditional probability in
one
direction to calculating in the other
direction so if you know e given F but
you don't know F given e Baye theorem is
your friend that is how you're going to
calculate it now you guys should
certainly write down all these rules and
you should have them in your back uh
envelope you don't have to have
memorized them for cs19 our midterm for
example is open book what you really
need to know how to do is how to use
these in the real world and be able
solve problems that we give you in cs19
and recognize instances of these
different rules and I promise we would
do a little bit of review by gambling
let's do it do you guys want to play a
game it's actually a game called poker
and one of the amazing things about
poker you imagine something that
computers would be great out because
computers can calculate perfect
probabilities but for the longest time
computers were not good at poker you
know why poker is a psychological game
you watch the other person you be like
you're lying or like you're definitely
about to win and you just showed it to
me there's this concept in poker that's
very important called it tell have you
ever seen somebody look at cards and you
notice in their face that they just got
a little
excited some people their face lights up
some people do more subtle things like
there's there's people who have patterns
where they always ACD touch their money
when they get
excited tells aren't perfect information
but they're information that you need to
use if you want to play this game of
poker
well so I'm going to imagine you're
playing against an
opponent and they may give a tell
they're much more likely to give a tell
that when they have a winning hand so if
they look at their cards and there's a
winning hand there's a 50% chance that
you'll see that excitement in their eyes
it might be the case that they have a
winning hand and you don't see the
excitement in their eyes totally
possible but they're just more likely to
show this tell if they've got a winning
hand if they don't have a winning hand
there's also a chance that you'll
misread something as excitement so
there's a chance that you'll see the
tell even if they just pulled two cards
that are
losing if we want to make a good
decision if you guys want to win this
game you're going have to reason about
uncertainty through this complicated
idea of AEL before I jump into the game
any questions about what AEL
is we've got a real game I've got a
program we're gonna play a game here
real money is going to be on the
line now this game is based off a real
poker game I don't care if you know the
rules of Poker I care that you guys know
probability and here's how the game's
going to be played your opponent is
going to have two cards now this isn't
the real game this is just a demo these
are your cards don't show them to me do
you have two okay fantastic I'm going to
you know during the course of the game
I'm going to see about let's say seven
cards in this EX example is that right 1
2 3 4 5 6 yeah I see seven
cards
and that g me some
information my version of this game is
very simple if you have an ace you win I
can change my belief about whether or
not you have an ace based off the cards
that I've
seen and I see your tell you had a stone
cold Poker Face you gave no tell that's
what this means there's not an excited
tell and then you guys get to choose to
play if you don't play you walk away no
questions asked if you do play if you
win $10 if I win $10 for
me there's extra card okay I'm not
cheating I promise I'm just you know
trying to put all the winning cards on
the ground we're not going to play with
those cards because I could have rigged
it instead we're going to pay the Run
game
I'm going to run it you guys
ready same
game your opponent has two unseen cards
actually what cards do you have by the
way ninees and 10 Hearts you didn't win
so that would be an example of the
opponent not winning but that's not the
game that's not the game we're going to
play on the computer that was just a
demo that's just a demo but they're
really fun cards right okay but this is
a live game and we have to calculate the
probility we have to make a good
decision under uncertainty using all the
tools that we've got so same game the
opponent has two cards I'm not going to
show them to you instead you have to
decide if you want to bet whether or not
one of those cards is an ace one of
those cards is an ace we lose opponent
wins bad
times you get some information in this
game you see all of these cards notice
how none of them are
Aces every card that's not an ace makes
it more likely that there's an ace in
your opponent's
hand but your OPP does not give you that
excited tell and just to recap the
probability of a
tell given that your opponent has an ace
is
50% this excited tell is a lot less
likely if your opponent doesn't have an
ace importantly notice how I use symbols
T is for tell and a is for Ace which is
the same as winning well that means your
opponent
won okay
hey I'm going to have somebody play this
game
but well actually can I get a
volunteer okay since you're in the front
come on up you get to volunteer but
we're going to do this together you're
going to need a marker we're going to
try and figure out what we need to know
in order to gamble right now you might
just be a gambling type and you're like
already know you're like I don't care I
don't care about the probability I just
want to play but we want to optimize
your chance of making a good decision
does that sound good y so let try and
figure out what's the problem we're
solving here oh by the way what's your
name
Alan this is a class class this is
everybody say
hi okay first of
all let's say I have these two
events what will determine whether or
not you want to
play the probability that they don't
have an ace yeah so if the probability
that they don't have an ace if that is
greater than
0.5
should you play yes okay we know what to
do then you just need to tell me what's
the probability that they don't have an
ace by the way what's this is very
related to the probability that they do
have an ace right just going to be one
minus okay we need to know the
probability that they have an ace
now this is an important thing you have
seen a
tell okay so it's a little bit more
interesting notationally than this it's
you know the probability they don't have
a given that you didn't see a tell right
we observe no
tell so the probability they don't have
an ace given that you observe no tell if
that's greater than 0.5 we play right
okay should we do this together okay
okay how do you want to approach this
I'll be your scribe so we want to know
the probability that they don't have an
ace given that they don't have a
tell right how do we approach this what
are our options so
if we use B theorem right good want to
get the opposite of this so probility
that they don't have a tell that they
don't have an
ace okay since we know that oh give me a
second okay you think about a little bit
while I write the rest of B
theorem sorry I'm not as fast as writing
as you are
thinking okay this is still in the
denominator I'm just you know bored
right we're
cool okay in B theorem you kind of
condition off of one event and then you
condition off the complement of that so
here there's this other thing which is
just the
probability that they do have an Ace and
the probably of no till given that they
do have an
ace do we have any of these numbers it
feels like no but kind of it's yes yes
oh we do okay fantastic which ones do we
have so I mean uh we have the
probability that they don't have the
tell given that they don't have the ace
what is that that's one minus the
probability that they have the tell
given that they don't have that's so
good you guys hear what he said said the
probably they don't have a tell given
that they have an a it's just going to
be one minus that so probability of the
this one we don't have this one we have
the probity of tell given Ace but you're
saying the probability of no tell given
Ace is just going to be one minus
fantastic that is just a
0.5
okay um do we have this yes by the same
logic okay and it
is9 oh this is fantastic this is going
so well 0.9 except for my handwriting
still bad and up here this is
0.9 is this problem under specified I
never told you the probability of a
you're like isn't that the thing we care
about what's the difference between
probability of a and and or let's say
the probably of a compliment and the
probably of a compliment given
tell well with the compliment you don't
have any information about the tell
exactly no information about the tell we
just have to think what's the chance
that the opponent doesn't have an ace as
it is how can we do that is there like a
base theorem for that no we just have to
count ah yeah great I'll just pull out
my deck of cards and start counting them
or we could do equal likely outcome
spaces okay so what are all the ways
that you're opponent could get two cards
well that's 52 choose two almost there's
seven I've already shown you choose
there's 45 choose two does that make
sense there's seven that we're not
including because we know it's not one
of those seven you can't choose one of
those seven and what are all the ways
that they don't have an
ace uh it's going to be
41o how' you get 41 just magical numbers
you just pull do you know the answer to
this already did you prep
why 41 so that's just all the cards that
are in an A in the deck so there's 45
cards and 41 of them are not Aces so
these are all the ways you can pull two
cards and these are all the ways you can
pull two cards where none of them are
Aces okay we can calculate this number
we can plug it in for that we're just
missing this which is going to be one
you want to just do it should we just
calculate this I think we should just
calculate this okay uh
python import math
math. combination 41 choose two d by
math. combination of 45 choose
two 83% chance hey there's an 83%
chance that that opponent is not is
going to lose would you want to play
this game well now we need to Valu with
the tell yeah we have to bring the tell
because they didn't have a tell so maybe
they actually do uh you know maybe that
gives us some information that we need
to incorporate okay so you can put 83%
in here oh my God should we just do this
whole thing
09 okay I'm going to call this a
variable I'm going to call this uh
a that's
this probability a complement okay so
0.9 time PAC divided by 0.9 * Pac plus
0.5 you're checking my math you should
check my
math
Pac so one minus Pac is just that
okay this is the
probability and now we have to interpret
this this is a probability that they
will a even that they don't J the T okay
you got a 90% chance of winning or
losing you winning do you want to play
sure 10 bucks you could just walk
away you win Everybody Run
Applause okay fantastic buy your friends
at
J oh you guys think I wouldn't pay
up I actually
yeah oh my mark yeah I don't keep the 10
bucks but give me my
marker it's a beauty of probability like
we don't have to just guess we can think
about this thing rationally a lot of
probability was invented by terribly
addicted gamblers we are not terribly
addicted gamblers but we can use the
same mathematics that they invented to
make more interesting decisions under
uncertainty okay 10 out of 10 most
important thing in CS 109 that we've
learned so far is BAS you really really
want to feel solid about this this was a
hard Bas theorem one because you had to
combine probabilities with equally
likelihoods and Bas theorem and you have
to think about a lot of conceptual
ideas okay did you guys feel good with
Bas theorem you're going to need a lot
of practice but do you at least
appreciate that this is something that
you will identify as worth
practicing yes awesome that's what I
wanted okay so that was just you know
the review for today a couple
announcements before we jump into new
content
our sections in CS 109 they start today
some people have sections on Wednesday
most people have sections on Thursdays
and a few people have sections on Friday
before class uh go to your section it's
an incredible part of Cs 109 you will go
through live problems now there's two
things to think about for a section one
it's a great chance for you to get more
practice you know I'm here in a lecture
and you don't get to work on the
problems in the depth that you really
need before you go into your problem
sets but the other part is we're a
community and you're going to join a
small group and one of the things you do
in section is give back to that
community help each other out we're all
a team if every single person in this
room walks out knowing cs19 we will all
feel successful and you know your grades
are not based on what other people in
this class do so let's help each other
out let's make a wonderful Learning
Community where everybody can make it
and section go there and learn and go
there and give back to others speaking
about giving back to others this is a
super like not important thing but
there's this new learn with others
button on the problem set app so if you
go over here wow 97 people learn with
others if you click it you can get match
with somebody it's not a obligatory part
of cs19 but boy would I appreciate if
you guys could stress test my
server and also help each other learn so
if you guys are up for it at 9:00
tonight would you guys mind just like
going there and hitting the button you
could spend five minutes just talking to
another person in class be like hi I'm
Chris woohoo probability or if you did
have a question about the the problem
set you guys could talk about it too um
so let's try this Peet party if you're
up for it totally optional the word of
the day is kind cat uh and you can write
that uh in the same way that we always
do okay are we done now that we've
learned Bas theorem like no there is so
much more to learn and to really
motivate this next great toic I wanted
to show you guys a a cool
program we all know about DNA so I'm
going to give you a context of DNA that
I think is quite interesting you're
going to be looking at a
100,000 examples of bats and for these
bats you're going to get six pieces of
information the first five pieces of
information are particular genes that
the bat will have or not have so every
row here is a bat and this is saying
they don't have this gene they don't
have this gene they don't have this gene
they do have this gene they don't have
this Gene and then finally you have a
trait something that we care about you
one of the things that people study in
bats are whether or not they're able to
carry Ebola and maybe you're curious
which of these genes is telling the
story of whether or not they can carry
aola wouldn't it be so cool if we could
just go from data like this to having an
understanding of where that causality is
coming from now of course we all know
from data you can't get perfect
causality but maybe we could start to
form a hypothesis about which genes are
causing which other traits does that
sound
interesting okay let's run this
program find
structure
okay make this bigger python fine
structure so I wrote a little program
it's going to look at all that data and
after looking at all that data it asked
me if I'd like to receive keystrokes
from my
applications uh
whatever I wrote this Python program and
it outputs a hypothesis and the
hypothesis it gives me is that I think
Gene file causes Gene 2 and I think the
presence of Gene one and Gene 2 is
what's controlling whether or not this
trait is expressed how cool would it be
if we could write programs like that now
I did a whole bunch of calculations to
get there and you see this word show up
over and over again independent and that
is the next great uh topic that's in our
cair is the thing we're going to be
learning about today so stay tuned learn
about independence so you can do really
cool things like WR this program
okay well we've gotten ahead of
ourselves we have to start at the
beginning of our story uh so let's start
about the beginning of our story we have
goals for today the goals for today is
to learn about properties of events that
make life easy the main property we're
going to focus on is independence and
Independence is going to make it easy to
do probability of end we're also going
to be learning about Mutual exclusivity
which is something we've seen before
we're going to revisit and as you recall
that makes it easy to do probability of
or if you walk out today feeling
comfortable these two things you've hit
the learning goals let's start with the
review of probability of or we've
already talked about the probability of
or if you have two events and you want
to calculate the probability of either
one or the other happening there's one
context that makes it very easy the
context that makes this very easy is if
there's no outcome in both
events it's not possible for both events
to occur at exactly the same time you
can just add the probability mass of one
event with the probability mass of
another
this is one of the axm of probability so
it's one of the things that's given
without proof it's one of the
foundational assumptions of probability
uh but it also makes a lot of sense you
know there's no outcome that's shared
between them then you can imagine
feeling how many outcomes are in E
getting that probability and then adding
the probability of alcom and f that
feels like a very intuitive reasonable
thing to do if you want the probability
of either of them
happening this property of mutual
exclusivity therefore is something
really interesting for you to look out
for if I give you two events I'd like
you guys to get to the point where you
can look at those events and decide are
they mutually
exclusive sometimes a problem will tell
you these two events are mutually
exclusive but a lot of times you might
have to just like look at the events and
reason is it possible for both of them
to occur at the same time if that answer
is yes they're not mutually
exclusive what about the case where
they're not mutually exclusive and while
you guys think about that there was a
question just based on your uh beginning
definitions can we see so something that
is independent can also not be mutually
well get independent in just a second so
let me let me that's such a good
question you're like wondering what's
the difference between Independence and
mutual I will tell you that but I'm just
let's get our heads around Mutual
exclusivity before we go into
Independence good question hold on to
it here's what the opposite of mutual
exclusivity looks like so this is when
it's possible for their for both events
to occur at the same time there are
outcomes that are in both events so both
events can happen at the same time
what's probability of or like in that
case it's very similar to Counting of or
uh when you have non-mutual exclusive
sets you take the probability of one
event add the probability of the other
event but it's like you've double
counted all this probability mass that
of all the outcomes that count as both
event e and event F and so you got to
subtract off that double
counting does that sound familiar from
sets nod your head if that sounds pretty
good okay we're in a great situation now
if you want to do probably of or think
about Mutual exclusivity if it's mutual
ex mutually exclusive just add and if
it's not you just use a slightly more
complicated formula feels good I'm going
to bump it up in a tiny tiny little
Notch uh but then you're done with
probability 4 you guys ready for more
than two
sets what if you care about the
probability of e or F or G so like you
know maybe e is that they have a tell
and F is that they have an Ace and then
G is like they went to the bathroom or
something like that and you want know
the probability of either one of those
things
happening how could you calculate this
using the underlying concepts of e and f
and
g okay we can start by thinking about
the probability of e I've got this neat
little ven diagram where I'm thinking
about all the events in F all the events
in E and all the events in G I'm
allowing for some events that are in
both E and F some events that are in
both e and G and some events that are in
all three I put a one in each of these
subsections say if I've used the
probability of e in my formula each of
these probability spaces has been
counted exactly once which is what we
want this would be the full answer if we
had a one in every single one of these
quadrants but we don't because we
haven't really thought about F or G
should we add those in too let's add in
the probability of f if you add in the
probability of f things are pretty good
except we've double counted the things
that are both in E and F and we've
double counted the things well this is
all the things are in both andf
following along so far so this is not
the formula because it doesn't count
every outcome exactly once we've double
counted some things and we haven't
counted this at all well let's count
this by adding probability of G and if
you add in the probability of G um then
we have uh this is counted once but this
is counted twice uh and why am
I hm I'm missing a step here okay
um okay well this is counted once this
is counted twice this is counted twice
and actually this should be counted
three times when I subtract andf this
goes down to a one and this goes from a
three to a two so I could I subtracted
off the space here and it got me a
little bit closer you know I could do is
I could subtract off one of these spaces
and if I subtract off one of these
spaces then all these numbers in this
space go down by one this is getting us
closer and then finally I've got this
final thing which is counted too many
times instead of doing the reasonal
thing and just subtracting off this
single quadrant I'm going to continue on
my crazy pattern of subtracting off
every pair and I'll subtract off every
pair so I have a formula where I added
every event on its own I subtracted off
every pair of events and if you look at
all the spaces and how many times
they're counted we're really really
really close we've counted everything
once but how come we counted this thing
zero times I thought we counted it three
times well we counted it one two three
times but then we subtracted it here we
subtracted it here and we subtracted it
here it got added three times subtracted
three times it's like we haven't even
counted it once so if you wanted three
events and you wanted the probability of
or if they weren't mutually exclusive
you'd have to use this whole honken
formula and the final thing is to add in
the sets of three do you guys Noti
something cute there's like all sets of
one minus all pairs of sets plus the
triplet of sets it's a little bit cute
there's some symmetry there what a
formula who here wants to use a formula
that
long nobody like one person is like yeah
a little bit I like long formulas um but
you know just the point here Mutual
exclusivity becomes important if you
have more than two events because this
formula does get a little bit
long I hope you never have to go here
but just so you know how deep this
Rabbit Hole goes we should talk about n
events
you know how here we like alternated
between like singles and doubles and
triples like we added all the singles
subtract all the doubles then added the
triples you kind of take that pattern up
to n you add all the singles you
subtract all the doubles you add all the
triples then if you go to four you
subtract all the quadruples if you go to
Five you add all the all the sets of
size five of the events in
sanity anyways there's this more General
inclusion exclusion I hope you never
have to use it but you should know that
it exists if if you ever feel like going
there and in fact the biggest learning
goal for you should be I hope to do
whatever I can mathematically to avoid
doing the probability of or of more than
three sets if they're not mutual
exclusive because this just becomes a
really really really crazy
formula
okay this little cuteness here is just
saying you're flipping negatives and
additions you can get into the formula
if you ever want to but as I said the
learning goal is do everything you can
to avoid using this
formula okay
so we have everything you need to do
probability of or if they're mutually
exclusive life is easy just add and if
it's not mutually exclusive you just use
this inclusion exclusion yes question I
have a question the V diagram why we
want all be one why don't we just want
the outer peripheries of e f and g one
uh you know this outer periphery means
all the events that only happen in F
and you do need to count all the things
that happen in both F and E all these
outcomes that are in F and E they should
be counted and they're not counted here
because these are the ones that are F
but are not e it's we let's talk about
the ven diagram afterwards um because
the derivation is less important than
the rule but I'd like to make sure that
people feel intuitive about the
derivation okay good
question okay so what do we do now is it
would be great if probability was only
about or but there's a lot of times when
you need the probability of and and so
it's time to learn about probability of
and and you know how there's this
probability Mutual exclusion that made
life easy for or there's this property
called Independence which is going to
make life easy for and if you can
identify that two events are independent
or if you're told it if you want
probability of and you just
multiply if you're told they're
independent probably if or doesn't get
any easier it's only probably if and
that gets easier and and just becomes
multiplication if two events are not
independent you have to revert back to
the chain rule which we've already
talked
about okay let's do probability van
let's learn about it and Independence is
the key uh feature that we're going to
think about for two events when we're
talking about probility
V the definition of Independence is
going to be intuitive but at the end of
the day it's mathematical just like
Mutual exclus meant that there's no
outcome in in both elements or in both
uh events the pro Independence is
defined as the probability of a is
exactly equal to the probability of a
given B There is semantics to that let's
think about what that means what's your
chance of a happening given no
information that's the same as your
chance of a happening given the
information that B has occurred that's a
long way of saying B told you nothing
when I told you B happened your chance
of a occurring didn't go up or down B
had no influence on your belief so it's
like an independent belief B occurring
is independent of a
occurring so if the intuition makes
sense for you great otherwise this is a
mathematical definition you can use if
this equation does not hold then they're
dependent now if we start with the chain
rule the chain rule says the probability
of a and b equals probity of a * the
probably of B given a if we use this new
definition of independence which says
that if probably B is if B is of a then
this condition is the same as
probability of
B this term becomes just probability of
B right that's what we defined and now
we're left with this really important
result about independence if a and b are
independent that means these two terms
are the same and as such the probability
of and is the multiple of the
probabilities on their
own that's why it matters so much
because it's going to make your
computations much easier if somebody
tells you things are independent it
makes computations is way way way way
way easier you don't have to do any of
this complicated conditional probability
if they're not independent you do have
to think about B given
a Independence is so powerful in lots of
advanced CS classes you'll see people
making Independence assumptions where
they don't belong we will assume things
that are not independent are independent
just because it makes math so much more
doable but anyways this is what
Independence means there now are two
ways of understanding Independence you
could either understand that these two
terms are the same or you could
understand Independence as if a and b
are independent then probably of a *
probabbly of B should be the probability
of A and
B
okay major key I like these major Keys
it's just like from lecture what's the
most important thing to know and one of
the most important things to know is if
you can find this property of
Independence in events probability of
and's going to become
easy this is a proof I include you don't
need to memorize but the proof tells you
that if I tell you a is independent of B
then it also must mean that b is
independent of a that might just make
sense to you guys um but you could prove
it by using Baye theorem so here's just
Bas theorem for B given a because a is
independent of B this term just becomes
probability of a which is going to
cancel with the denominator and you're
left with the probability of B given a
equals probability of B so if I assume
that term which is that a is independent
of B I can prove that b is independent
of a just so you
know okay let's try this using dice so
I'm going to think about two different
dice dice one and dice
two let e be the event that the first
dice is a one and let F be the event
that the other dice is a
one can we show that they're independent
here's what that would look like I would
calculate the probability of e on its
own what's the probability that this
dice is a
one six what's the probity that this
dice is a one six what's the probability
that E and F occur
together there's only one outcome where
both e is true and F is true and that's
the outcome where one was one and the
other one was one there's 36 different
outcomes of the two dice and only one of
them simultaneously satisfy E and F it's
certainly possible for E to be true and
for f to be false uh but if both E and F
are false that means you know the value
of the two dice and there's just that
one out of 36 outc
comes 16 * 16 is exactly 1 over 36 this
isn't always the case it's only the case
if your two events are independent and
these two events are independent let's
think about this conceptually if I tell
you this first dice is a one does it
change your belief in the outcome of
this dice no there's no complicated
quantum entanglement between these dice
this dice gives you no information as to
what outcome will come from this dice so
being told the outcome of one dice
doesn't change your belief in the
outcome of the other other that's the
conceptual way of understanding but
really if somebody asks you to show
Independence you should mathematically
prove it what we have on the board okay
let's try another one I have a new event
G and G is the event that the sum of the
two dice is five out of my 36 different
outcomes here are all the outcomes that
satisfy G A 1 and four 2 and three 3 and
two and a four and one the probability
of G is going to be equal to 4 over 36
there's four
outcomes that satisfy G out of your 36
possible outcom
comes
now if I want to show if e is
independent of G so recall that e is
that the first dice is a
one the probability that the first dice
is a one is a 1 over six and the
probability of e and G well that's an
interesting one well here's all the
outcomes that satisfy G out of these
outcomes which ones also satisfy e are
there
any there's this one this one satisfies
that the first dice is a one and the
second dice is a four so it's both the
case that the two dice add up to five
and it's the case that the first dice is
a one so there's one out of 36 outcomes
where both e and G are true I've
calculated each of these on their own if
you multiply 16 * 4 over 36 it turns out
you do not get 1 over 36 this is an
example of dependent
events now this is interesting if
they're depend
another way of saying the mathematical
thing that we proved is that by telling
you that the first dice is a one I
change your belief that the two dice
will add up to
five that kind of makes sense I told you
the first dice was one if I told you the
first dice was a six does that change
your belief that the two dice add up to
five yeah cuz it's not going to add up
to five if your first dice is a six so
telling you that the first dice is one
kind of means like few I avoided the
case if you rolling a six on the first
dice I've still got a chance of the two
dice adding up to five when one event
changes the belief in another event
that's dependence and you would prove it
using this sort of mathematical
derivation yeah questions would it be
correct to say that whether G happens
depends on whether G
happens yeah there there's I want to add
a little bit to that so the the question
was is it correct to say that whether G
happens depends on whether e happens yes
to be more General though I'd say e
happening changes my belief in whether
or not g will happen cuz we're in this
beautiful world of probability things
are generally not deterministic uh and
it's when something happens like you
roll a one it doesn't tell you whether
what what D or whether or not the sum
will be five it just changes your
probability that the sum will be five so
exactly the averse event happening
changes your probability in the other
event
happening question in the back yeah
we're talking about um epistemic
probability basically a couple of days
ago right I think a couple of lects ago
can you explain how basium kind of fits
into that they using the word beliefs so
often yeah I will always I think of
probabilities as representing beliefs uh
I always think about it as not just
representing stochasticity in the world
but my own uncertainty I feel like this
example from the med of class really
captures that this probability of the
other person having no Aces we can know
that EXA exactly cuz counting tells us
exactly how to calculate it but as soon
as I got into this world of I have to
infer this complicate idea of a I really
do enter this world where I'm not
exactly sure how the world works and I
use probabilities to represent my own
uncertainty and you know base theorem
all these laws of probability allow us
to combine those two things these softer
beliefs with some hard mathematical
calculations and you can bring it
together into probabilities as such
you'll almost always hear me use belief
as a synonym for
probability such a good philosophical
question
okay I do want to give you guys a chance
to talk to the person next to you see if
you can talk to person next to you and
Define what Independence is and see if
you can come up with a clarifying
question because this is an important
part of lecture is there anything
confusing about this see if you can sus
it out talk to the person next to
you
okay that was just a short
chat any questions come
up I once had somebody asked me this
really wild question I love questions
questions are you engaging with the
unknown it's like the most beautiful
beautiful way of articulating learning I
just love love love a good question and
once while I was teaching 109 somebody
asked me this question that I just
thought was very especially gorgeous so
I thought I would share it with you guys
student raised their hand and said you
showed me what Mutual exclusivity looks
like those are those two events that
don't overlap can you show me what
Independence looks like and at first I
was like yeah and I had to think about
it and I thought about it I was like oh
that's such a beautiful
question first of all this is is not
what Independence looks like this is a
visualization of a sample space so you
can imagine every outcome is just like
some pixel in this square and I have two
events in the sample space b and a they
don't overlap at all that's what Mutual
exclusivity looks like this is a picture
of I'm saying it's not possible for both
A and B to occur simultaneously
therefore they're mutually exclusive
mutually exclusivity also means that the
probability of A and B is equal to
zero and so if you thought about you
know um whether or not this is
Independence if that leftand side is
zero is it the case that probably of a
times probably of B should be
zero no we feel like these are both two
nonzero numbers if you multiply two
nonzero numbers you shouldn't get this
probability of zero which is the
probability of both of them happening
this is mutual exclusivity it's not what
Independence looks like which begs the
question what does independence look
like
this is what Independence look like so I
think this is a useful way of thinking
about it let's use this Independence
definition two Independence definition 2
says that probability of a is equal to
the probability of a given that b
happens and if you think about that the
probability of a is like how big is a
relative to the sample space and a given
B if you use the the definition of
conditional prob but it's like how big
is a and b relative to the size of the
outcome
B it's saying that this ratio of a to
the sample size is equal to the ratio of
a b to
B it might be helpful or interesting to
people this is certainly not the 10 out
of 10 important thing from today's
lecture but it's really claiming that if
you talk about the chance of a happening
if you collapse to the world where B has
happened a is just as likely to occur
and so takes up the same ratio so this
is a good picture of what Independence
looks like there has to be some chance
of both of them occurring and it should
be the case that if B occurs then you
have the exact same ratio of a to the
possible outcomes as you did before you
knew B occurred this is not an example
of Independence this is what dependence
looks like because the ratio of a to the
alcome
space it's smaller than the ratio of a b
to B so when you collapse into the world
where B has happened a becomes more
likely I think the most intuitive way of
understanding Independence is really
just to Think semantically Through what
this means that's a mathematical truth
these are pictures which are also true
but I think that's really where you get
the conceptual understanding of
Independence if I tell you that one
event happens it doesn't change your
belief that the other event
happens okay proof one other great way
to get
intuition you guys might be wondering
about compliments we've haven't been
thinking that much about compliments but
I want to leave you feeling
reassured that if I tell you two events
are independent it is also the case that
an event is independent of the
complement of the other so if I tell you
A and B are independent you can also
know that a is independent of B
compliment who doesn't love a good
proof so by a laot of pro to probability
probability of a is equal equal to the
addition of two different sets A and B
plus A and B complement and this has
been rearranged a little bit you know
law of total probability it
says probability of a can come from two
sources probability of A and B plus the
probability of A and B complement and
you kind of have the that idea that B
and B
complement are background processes in
which a occurs and you thinking about
this probability Mass plus that probity
Mass Gives You probability of a if you
took that equation rearranged it You'
get this first line and nicely on this
first line we have a b complement on the
left hand side so I just rearranged this
so that that's on the left hand side of
the
equation now I told you A and B were
independent so this term here is going
to split or on my slides this term over
here and I can split it either to say or
I can split it to say that this is the
same as probably of a * probability of B
now I can factor out probability of a
and this becomes probability of a * 1
minus probability of B and 1us
probability is just probably B
compliment I want you guys to see what
proofs in probability look like the main
learning goal of cs19 is more that you
can apply probability in the real world
and to algorithms that make decisions
under uncertainty not so much that you
guys have to regurgitate proofs but
proofs are one way to gain that
intuition you can really believe me when
I tell you if I tell you A and B are
independent you know a is independent of
B compliment and of course it goes the
other way around
too man are we close to adding to the
final layer of your fundamental tool set
remember when we talked about or and in
the two event case it wasn't so bad but
then you got to the three event case and
it just became
awful we have to generalize with and to
we have to talk about and when there's
more than two events I know I don't want
to put that stress on you guys you don't
want that stress but we just got to know
you guys want to do
[Laughter]
it I have fantastic news for you to
start sometimes you have many events and
you're allowed to make the assumption
that they're all independent of one
another and if you have many events and
you're told they're all independent the
probability of E1 and E2 and E3 and e r
is as simple as just multiplying those
probabilities together you know probably
E1 time prob E2 * proba E3 * probility
of e r a great example of this is coins
we often assume that the outcome of each
coin is independent of any other flip so
even if you have a 100 coins and you
want to know the probability of the end
of particular set of outcomes you can
just multiply those probabilities
because we assume all coins even if
there's more than two of them are
independent this is similar to Mutual
exclusivity if you're doing or and many
of your events are mutual exclusive it's
just a big old sum the problem wasn't
when our special uh property was
satisfied it's when it's not we need to
know how you do probably and when this
special case of Independence isn't
satisfied oh I do have an example though
um so we can talk about whether or not
we figure out if more than two events
satisfy
independent you guys ready for this this
is a little bit more work for you guys
to really get your head around this
important concept of Independence now
with three
sets I have two events e is that dice
one is a one f is that dice 2 is equal
to a six and my third event G is that
the sum is
seven if you want to claim that more
than two events are independent you'd
have to show that every combination of
subsets of the events are also
independent so let's try it are these
three events
independent okay first of all are e and
G independent oh you know they are you
know one oh this is maybe surprising
what's the probability of e that you get
a one on this dice one
six we learned this earlier the
probability that the sum of two dice of
seven is also one over six because
there's there's six outcomes you got a
one and a six uh a two and a five a
three and a four four and a three a five
and a two and a six and one there's six
out of 36 outcomes uh where G is
satisfied so the probably the sum of two
dice of seven is also 1 over six what's
the probability that the first dice is a
one and that the sum is uh
seven the probability the first dice is
one the sum is s is 1 over 36 because
there's just one outcome where the first
dice is one if I tell you the first dice
is a one there's just one remaining
assignment to the second dice so that
the sum is equal to seven there's just
one outcome out of 36 and 1 6 and 1 6 =
1 over 36 e and G are in fact
independent now are E and F independent
yes you know we just think of the two
dice ruls as being independent of each
other there's a one six chance of
getting a one there's a one six chance
of getting a six and there's one over 36
chance of getting exactly one over six
or sorry a one and six so check E and F
are independent check e and G are
independent are f and g
independent so if I tell you f that your
second dice is a six is an independent
from knowing the sum of seven what's the
chance second dice is six one six what's
the chance that the two dice add up to
seven one six what's the chance that
both of these happen Okay well this one
had to be a six and for the two dice to
be adding up to seven there's only one
choice for this other dice so there's
one out of 36 outcomes where both f and
g are true and this times this equals
this we are on a
roll but finally if you want to really
claim that e and f and g are independent
you also have to show that the probably
of e and f and g is equal to the proba
of e * probably f * probably G what's
the chance that you roll a one so this
event is true you roll a six so this
event is true and that g event that the
sum is seven is
true there's just this one
outcome so there's a 1 over 36 chance of
all three being true
simultaneously and that is not equal to
16 * 1 16 * 16 long story short here if
you're told that many events are
independent that's a stronger claim cuz
they've told you that any subset of
those events are also independent if you
would like to prove that multiple events
are independent then you'd have to prove
that for every single subset they're all
independence holds which is a little bit
insane uh but as I said Independence is
something so powerful that we see it in
the world but also we assume it pretty
often okay we've got ourselves a new
ability Yeah question I have a question
about the intuition behind this one in
the last question when we rolled a one
it did affect the the probability that
you get a St but in this case it
didn't that why do that
happen here for e and f and g so all of
these pairwise looked independent it's
just when you thought about all three of
them together that it didn't and think
about it this way if I tell you that e
is true N I tell you that f is true does
it change your belief that g is true so
E I tell you what's on the first dice F
I tell you what's on the second dice
does it change your belief about what's
the sum of the two dice absolutely so
that's why the triplet intuitively is
breaking down because telling you about
the outcome of two events is certainly
influencing the
third and when we actually looked at
pairs of events you know being told the
outcome of one wasn't changing our
belief uh in the other but was just when
we looked at all three that Independence
fell
apart wildness okay Independence is a
strong claim just to clarify the proof
that we do in the very end um why is it
that I test is always a probability of
all happening versus probability of each
single one happening and why do we
multiply them together uh that's just
the independence claim the independence
claim means must be the case that each
event multiplied to itself gives you the
probability of and and we're testing if
that's true and so it's test it's not it
it would have been true if they were
independent since they're not
independent it is not true it is
sufficient to show that these are not
equal to show they're not independent
and it's sufficient to show they are
equal to show that it is independent
question if G sums to a different number
besides seven could that potentially
change the independence my whole example
would break down seven was the magical
example that makes this whole thing work
uh we're going to talk about that a lot
more in depth later uh but that's a
little bit for later I will give you one
hint why is a sum of seven so
magical it's because for any outcome on
the first dice there's exactly one
outcome on the second I that will lead
to a seven and now we're getting to the
meta decision making for why I chose
this example but you know there's a
little bit of depth to the madness but
anyways the point here isn't how I chose
the example it's just for this
beautifully chosen example we've got a
lot of
Independence okay good questions
learning goals for
today if you have events if they're
independent probably and becomes easy if
you have events Mutual exclusive makes
or easy those are two different
properties and you want to keep them
separate uh in mutual exclusive means
there's no outcome in both events
independent means one event doesn't
change your belief in the other
happening oh I forgot to give you guys
the generalized chain rule if you can't
show that multiple events are
independent here's how you do do the
probability of A and B and C and we've
talked about this lightly but it's just
worth putting out there so what's the
probability of A and B and C if they're
not
independent you use chain rule but you
just keep going that's the probability
of
a times the probability of B given
a times the probability of C given a and
b if you had more than three events
you'd keep adding in another product and
the products would have these growing
growing conditional
dependencies now if they're independent
basically you can drop all of
that and so if this property holds it's
just the products of the uh the events
themselves and if you can't show
Independence you have to think about the
conditionals
okay it's time for some
practice here's a practice use a little
bit of genetics it's a softer use of a
genetics than the thing we started with
at the beginning of
class two parents have genes for whether
or not their kids have curly hair and
we're going to assume that both parents
have one dominant and one recessive gene
you don't need to know too much about um
probability here but if you have these
sorry you don't need to know too much
about genetics you need to know a lot
about probability if you have two
parents with one dominant one recessive
the child will only have curly hair if
it both gets the recessive from the
mother and from the the father if
there's a 50% chance of getting from the
mother and a 50% chance of getting from
the father assuming they're independent
the chance of any single child having
this curly hair trait is
0.25 so I tell you that the gene you get
from your mother is independent of the
gene you get from your father you only
have curly hair if you happen to get
recessive from each because they're
independent we can multiply the 05
chance of getting recessive from your
father with the 0 five for your mother
this all leads to just a piece of the
setup of this problem these this couple
is having kids and every kid has a 25%
chance of having curly
hair there's three children what's the
probability that all three children have
curly
hair if you didn't know that each child
was independent and each child is
independent knowing one kid has curly
hair if you already know the genes of
the parent it doesn't change your belief
that the next child has curly hair it's
like a next roll of the dice or your
next coin
flip if you didn't know Independence you
would have to use this generaliz chain
roll which would have been annoying
you'd have to think what's the chance
the third kid has curly hair given that
the first kid has curly hair and the
second kid has curly hair you'd probably
have to use some nasty Bay theorem since
I tell you that each kid is independent
this is going to reduce to
multiplication
yes um so about the expansion of the
chain R does the order matter for the
conditional prop you no that's the one
thing on your on your in your favor is
you ask does the order matter and it
turns out no you could do E3 E2 give
given an E3 and E1 give an E2 and E3 uh
but you'll still have a lot of similar
complexity um is just you know if you
think about it at the end of the day it
will give you an expression for all
three of them happening you know this is
E1 and E2 in the world that E1 happened
this is E3 in the world where E1 and E2
and if you put all those three things
together you get E1 E2 and E3 happening
and all those constructions lead to a
world where E1 E2 E3
happen so fantastic
this is a lot of complexity just to lead
to a relatively simple answer if there's
a 25% chance of one kid being curlyhair
the chance of all three of them kid one
and Kid 2 and kid three is just going to
be straight multiplication so it'll be
0.25 to the^ of three and we can do that
um we can go uh and do some Python and
we can do
0.25 to the^ of 3 which is the same as
0.25 * 0.25 * 0 . 25 um the chance of
all three kids having curly hair is
about
16%
okay here's another example to show you
how Independence could be helpful and
this one's a little it's just one step
harder than that previous one now you
guys know the Internet connects
computers Like A and B if you haven't
there's a YouTube video about that
that's not important right now and that
A and B are they're connected through a
whole bunch of different routers in this
case we're going to assume that they're
connected through n different routers
but they could fail and they could fail
with different probabilities like this
could be the path between my computer
here in the Facebook server in Oregon
this one goes up the coast this one goes
up the mountains you know there's all
these different
paths they have different probabilities
of failing and if any path is not failed
then there is a connection from A to B
the thing I'm interested in is what's
the probability of a functional path
from me to say the Facebook server to be
more abstract from computer a to
computer B this is a great example of a
canonical Independence question you know
if I put this on the midterm I'd really
hope that everyone gets it right though
it is a little bit hard why don't you
take a second and talk about this with
the person next to you because this is a
10 out of 10 important Independence
example
okay I want to set this problem up and I
want to set this problem up in a way
that
leads to a dead end because I want you
to see the dead ends as well as the good
ways to solve this we want probability
of e I'm going to define a whole bunch
of other events that are going to make
my life easier I'm going to Define X1
that path one is functional X2 means
path 2 is functional and X means that X
n's path is functional so you can
imagine you have like all these XIs
where X1 is this is making it X2 is this
is making it the question is in fact
asking this is is asking is there a path
X1 or is there a path X2 or is there a
path xn if any of these are true then
there is in fact a functioning
path now when I see a problem with or
the first thing I go is I look for
Mutual
exclusivity I don't have mutual
exclusivity I've been told independent
but maybe Mutual exclusivity exists for
Mutual exclusivity to exist it must not
be possible for two of these to be true
at the same time is it possible for two
of these to be true at the same time oh
yeah absolutely it's totally possible
and in fact likely for two paths to be
functional simultaneously therefore it's
possible for both X1 and X2 to be true
can't use Mutual exclusivity doesn't
hold so here's the really dark path to
go down you're like well Mutual
exclusivity doesn't hold let's use
inclusion
exclusion so it's like probably of X1
plus X2 plus X up to xn then subtract
off all the pairs then add in all the
triplets then subtract off all the
quadruplets and of course there's n of
these they haven't even told us how many
they are and like you just start
sweating profusely and you're like why
Chris do you make me do this in fact I
don't want you to do that that's why I
show you that there's other ways did
find somebody find another path to
happiness that didn't include going down
that inclusion exclusion yeah so we're
looking at an at least one scenario so
instead you can calculate the
probability that none of them are
functioning and then subtract that from
one okay one minus the probability that
none are
functioning I like how you said we're
looking at an at least one scenario
because that's really a good clue that
you want to do this one minus trick
because at least one is annoying but you
know maybe it's just it's always true to
be equal to one minus probability of
none of them work and you know what this
probity that none of them work I can
express that in terms of and
you know is the probability of X1
complement and X2
complement you know and up to xn
complement because it's the probability
that none of them are functioning is
saying that you know this one's not
functioning and this one's not
functioning they've all
broken and the reason this is so
beautiful is because now I've got an an
problem what does an care about it cares
about independence do we have
Independence
absolutely the problem told us to assume
that the routers were independent you're
like it told us the routers functions
are independent are the routers failing
independent yeah we proved that earlier
in class you know if X1 is independent
of X2 then X1 compliment is also
independent of X2
complement so we have ourselves a
situation where all of these are anded
and we know they're independent that
therefore this whole term just becomes a
whole big product so it's going to be
equal to 1 minus the product
over I of probability of x i
complement we're not given the
probability of XI complement we're given
the probability of x i so Pi is the
probability of a functioning x i
complement is just going to be one minus
that so it's going to be you know one
minus the probability of the first
router failing times one minus the
probably second router of failing time
oneus wait of succeeding oh jeez p p Pi
is the probability that it's functioning
so one minus probability of the first
one functioning time one minus
probability of the second one
functioning * 1 Min is probably the
third one functioning and each of these
is going to be you
know 1 minus Pi I Pi is the probability
of the I one
functioning that all leads to the
probability of all of them failing and
it's one minus the probability of all of
them failing the and allowed us to think
about each one on its own and just
multiply those things together this was
a dead
end questions about
this
yeah this one yeah this is just you know
if I didn't write this
notation it would look like this
probability of x i complement time
probability of X2 complement time
probability of X3
complement you know a Shand notation of
all this multiplication you know how
this is like the big old sum short hand
for lots of sun this is the Shand for
lots of multiplications so this says for
loop I times and every time multiply
this term so probability of x i
complement and this is like the index in
your for Loop so this is like a for Loop
multiplication this is a for Loop
addition okay this is all in your notes
in case you wanted to check it out in a
slower Pace than we went over it
now the most important
example that I can think of is this one
it's going to seem a little bit abstract
but because it's so important I actually
spent a lot of time and I put together a
full interactive demo in the course
reader if there is one thing to really
really focus on to make sure you're
getting all these Concepts together is
this idea of many coin flips and I have
a central question for you my central
question for you is imagine a world
where I flip 10 coins what's the
probability of getting exactly some
number of heads so maybe exactly six
heads if I flip 10 coins that might not
seem like such a deep question but I
promise you that if you think about this
question and if you understand it deeply
it's going to illuminate so much of the
next section of Cs
109 now I'm going to do a weird thing
with my coins
I'm going to allow my coins to be heads
with a different probability than 0.
five so this is a normal coin it's got a
probability being heads at 0.5 if I flip
10 of them you know you could get an
outcome like Tails heads Heads Tails
Tails Tails Tails heads heads heads and
you know like if you feel like doing
this a whole bunch without actually
getting out coins you can hit a whole
bunch oh my God that's so much fun
computers are
incredible I'm going to do something a
little bit funny I'm going to allow us
to have these weird coins that have
probabilities of not. five the reason
this example is so important is not
because we care about coins is because
coins are a metaphor for so many
processes in the world and not all those
processes are going to have a 05
probability of heads and to allow for
this metaphor to be so powerful I'm
going be thinking about coins that can
come up heads with different
probabilities so if I make this a 90%
chance of being heads notice how many
more are
heads often all of them um and I'm going
to just for now think about a 60% chance
so the core question is you flip a coin
10 times what's the chance of exactly
six heads we're going to get there in
order to get there we're going to think
through a series of problems that are
going to build up complexity of thinking
about Mutual exclusivity and
Independence together okay here's my
first warm-up for you
guys if I flip 10 coins each coin has a
60% chance of being a heads I hope you
guys can see this what's the chance of
getting heads heads Heads 10 times in a
row are coins independent absolutely the
out of one coin doesn't change the
outcome of another coin your belief
doesn't get updated as such since
they're independent what's the chance of
exactly this
outcome okay I heard two different
things I heard 1 12 to the power of 10
and I heard 6 to the power of 10 uh why
don't you guys just yell out loud which
one you like
more yeah okay 6 is the probability of
the first one being heads you have to
multiply by 6 is probably the second one
being head multiplied by 6 itself 10 *
is 6 to the^ of
10 in this case um you know it's going
to p p to the power of n um then you
could plug this in and get a number how
about this what's your chance of getting
this tail tail tail tail tail tail tail
10 times are they still independent even
though they're not heads yes yeah this
is the complement and the compliment is
still
independent
okay so4 is the probability of the first
coin being a Tails 1 minus 6 and we're
going to multiply by the chance of the
second coin being a Tails that's 04 you
multiply that by the chance of the third
coin being a taals that's point4 you
multiply by point4 by itself 10 times
okay great you guys ready to bump this
up a
notch heads I know I'm doing this slowly
but it's just that important four heads
and then six tails what's the chance of
that one talk about with the person next
to you for a second we're getting to
that level complexity in this case order
does matter I say the first four are
exactly heads and the next six are
Tails
okay if you got this answer great if you
didn't get the answer I'm about to write
think about where your misconception is
and then see if you can ask a clarifying
question so I'm assuming that order
matters this is the first heads the
probability getting the first coin as a
head is going to be
0.6 it's independent of the next coin so
the probability of the next coin of coin
number two being ahead is going to be
0.6 now I'm multiplying 0.6 by itself a
whole bunch of times so I don't want to
do that I'm going to use a power instead
how many times do I multiply
6 yeah because there's four heads now
I've talked about the probability of
these four events simultaneously
occurring so all of them occurring it's
not like they have to well all events
occurred they didn't have to happen in
the exact same moment in time but they
all occurred um after this one run of
the experiment I haven't talked about
the outcome of the next six coins
they're all
tals and the probability of the first
tals is
0.4 it's independent of the second tals
so I'd also multiply by another 0.4 I
don't want to write multiplying this
thing by itself six times because that
would be tedious so instead I'm going to
use
powers you might have just put 0 4 in
here I prefer to do 1 minus 0.6 that way
you don't have to worry about where this
magical point four comes from it's just
6 was my probability of a heads so
probability of heads is 6 probability of
tails is 1us 6 I slightly prefer that
you guys buying this so
far here's where it gets
tricky I now want to know the
probability of exactly K heads so I want
to know the probability let's say k
equals 4
I want to know the probability that if
you flip 10 coins that you get exactly
four why is that a different problem
than this
one this I want exactly K heads that
seems like what we calculated before can
someone tell me one reason that these
two are different yes an idea because
the heads could be like at any point the
10 with okay heads but for the first
example you had to be the first four
yeah what we calculated here was like
first four heads and then six tails
exactly like that but to be exactly K
heads your heads could have occurred
anywhere it could be the last four coins
you could have had them you know
interspersed differently
throughout
here's one example of heads or four
heads out of 10 can I give you another
one Tails heads Tails heads Tails heads
well I've got three so far right Tails
heads so now I've got four 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9
10 so here I
have another example we now have two
different examples of
orderings where there's exactly four
heads are there
others how many you're like oh my god do
I know how to do that counting before
you think about doing that counting can
I just show you all of them
computers are so
beautiful there's a lot of
them these are all the different ways of
getting exactly four heads all the
different
outcomes so then my question is how many
are there and I did see a hand go up for
an idea how many are there 10 choose
four 10 choose four how did you get
there yeah yeah yeah we want to choose
out of the 10 place places for slots to
turn into heads to choose to be heads
okay and then the rest aren't in our set
of heads you are not wrong you in fact
right sorry that that's so cheeky you
got it right but there was a different
way of thinking about this that leads to
the exact same
answer yes it's like if you have 10
letters it's like Mississippi like how
do rearrange it's Mississippi but
instead of like a beautiful River you've
got this really crappy word that's got
six T's and four h's and it's how many
ways can you do permutations with these
indistinct objects permutations where
these six T's look indistinct and these
four h's look indistinct if it was
permutations with indistinct objects you
get n factorial divided by how many you
know our heads that's K factorial times
how many are Tails that's n minus K and
that's factorial and that is equivalent
to n choose K two conceptual ways of
thinking about about how to count this
but both of them lead to there's n
choose K different
outcomes I have bad news for you guys
the probability of exactly K heads is
going to be a big old or it's the
probability of this outcome or this
outcome or this outcome we're going to
do have or but not of two outcomes or
two events but rather and choose K
different
events mind blowingly awful but
somebody's like it's not awful Chris
hold
Faith why might this not be
awful yes it doesn't matter
because sorry one more time because they
will evaluate to the same thing they
will evaluate to the same thing so
actually when you do multiplication each
one has the same probability but there's
another reason this is not
awful yes are independent of they're not
independent close
though they're mutually exclusive so
probability of or gets easy when they're
mutually exclusive independent says that
knowing one of these is the outcome
doesn't change your belief in the others
but if you tell me this is the outcome I
know this one didn't happen they're
mutually exclusive because it's not
possible to get this exact Arrangement
and to also get this exact Arrangement
so these two outcomes can't occur at the
exact same time they're mutually
exclusive which means if you want the
probability of the or of each of these
you can add up the probability of this
one plus the probability of this one
plus the probability of this
one it's just going to be a sum like
this probility of exactly K heads is
going to be a sum over every Row in that
the probability of that particular row
someone's already said it though no
matter which row you look at if there
are exactly four heads the probability
of that row will be the four heads
wherever you find them will each be a p
the six tails will each be a one minus P
so no matter which row you look at the
probability of each row is P4 * 1 - P to
^ 6 so if you sum up the probability of
each row and you plug in that each row
has exactly this and then you realize
this is a sum that doesn't use the eyes
you end up with there's n choose K rows
every row has this probability since
we're summing up that thing n choose K
times it will be n choose K times the
probability of one row isn't that
beautiful it brings like all the
concepts we learned into the exact same
example if there's one thing to study
learn this example forward backward it's
so helpful for just understanding all
your tools but also taking this to the
next level have a wonderful day come
back on Friday we will continue this
conversation